[Music]
where should agents be trying to
innovate
in 2021 clubhouse
[Applause]
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
what's going on gary dude is that a dude
is that a dunkin donuts cup yeah i think
dunkin donuts is better than starbucks
i think starbucks i don't know if that
hurts anyone's feelings
but i gotta make i hope vaynermedia is
not pitching for starbucks business as
i'm like doing this video
um but uh perfect timing tyler like
taking a sip and you brought me in but
great to see everybody uh love that been
reading a lot of comments
caught tom's last couple of minutes
michael price dante
um brianna mason good to see everybody
thanks for having me how are you tyler
yes super super excited to have you gary
man i was telling really the preface to
start
your influence on everyone watching but
also your influence on everyone speaking
is so huge so um we're super excited to
hear
what you have to say about the real
estate industry right now what's your
take on it so
uh without further ado you didn't you
need no introduction man so i'll let tom
and you take it away
tom you have the questions lined up
correct no
you don't okay um i shouldn't have super
it's super easy if you give
uh gary and i a couple minutes i'm sure
we will be just fine
yeah well i can uh yeah alex could have
those
um if not i have them handy as well so i
can jump into question number one if you
have
two yeah let's do it we like having you
part of this tie yeah
yeah i love it too man so let me get
into it let me uh pull it up here
while you're pulling it up just because
i hate dead air um
it is really scary how consistent you
know it's like
even when you just said your thoughts on
a real estate agent industry i'm like
jesus like especially you know in tom's
world where i've had some interaction
through the years
like what what i'm lucky about is that
clubhouse or tick-tock or
ott like hulu like the fact that most
people here
when they realize they're going to be
running hulu ads right or spotify
ads in between music and podcasts
because they're going to be bought like
facebook
is going to blow their mind right
because it's one people think one thing
about like social media
it's not as big but it was but it was in
my mind and i think i've been
historically correct about this it was
bigger
than tv and billboards and bunch bench
ads
that's about to happen with other things
right like there's a new spotify ad
product
yeah where you can self-serve you can
literally be like hey everybody
sorry to interrupt your music this is
tom ferry you know i'm in the pasadena
area like
selling homes if you're in the markets
tomferry.com t-o-m-f-e-r-r-y dot com
and that you can record that on your
phone and place it the way you place an
instagram ad
when everybody here figures out that
that's happening on something as big as
spotify where everybody is like
listening to music
or podcasts do that's gonna excite
people when they realize the videos they
make
for facebook even the janky ones
the phone stuff the stuff i believe in
that they're gonna be able to start
placing that on a biddable platform on
hulu
or roku or amazon fire stick and now
literally they're ant
or or more likely as as it ages up with
ott their nephew
says uncle tom i just saw a commercial
for you while i was watching
friends the you know what i always knew
about social was
it was so big that it would eat the
world
what i didn't anticipate because it was
just too impossible to see was
it's eating the radio and television
world because the way of marketing
you know is so interesting that
it it's better it's localized it's
targeted
so you know nfts are now brewing
vr and ar are really truly now
i'm either you know i'm in the stage of
vr
i bought bitcoin ah today's a big day
for me coinbase is going public right
now
this second right it is my for all the
accolades
of facebook and twitter and tumblr
and uber and pinterest and all the
things i've invested in
vayner rc my fund in 2014 invested in
coinbase
and the return is extraordinary and so
today is like my biggest
ipo of my career right congrats man yeah
congrats to that
this is not a humble brag or that it's
that in 2014
i understood that cryptocurrency had a
place that
you know that this was a real thing that
blockchain was a real thing that is
seven years ago 99 of the people on this
call right now still have no clue
or 90 no clue eight percent dabbling
might have a little bit of the
all of us including me we're all getting
this is the year of that right we're all
like oh [ __ ] i can't not know
about this anymore right yeah that
the reason i bring that up is because
i'm in that place right now with vr
okay i'm gonna now start to go a little
deeper
you may not see a single post
from garyvee about it for three years
i'm going behind the curtain to talk to
all of you
not because of that you need to go rush
and invest in vr
but because i want you to understand
that the only thing that matters is
attention
what do you do in the real estate
business you need people's attention
you need people's attention so they say
oh i like tyler i like
spencer i like todd back i like patricia
jimenez
that's that's what you need i like and
trust
natalie langford whether whether you saw
that as
you know cleveland's top broker as a
billboard whether you heard that on the
radio whether that came through on a
facebook post
whether that's your aunt told you that
that's who she used
to buy whether you've been 23 years
leading it or you're a kid that's
wearing a good suit because you're
trying to act
older and presentable whatever it is
it's all the same game
does somebody know i exist and will they
then do business with me
what i do and what i want everybody here
to do is understand
that if you don't obsess
over the first part the second part
doesn't matter
yep you can be the greatest realtor of
all time
based on god but if you go and yell that
god said i'm the best in the backwoods
of hudderlin county new jersey where i
did high school
and nobody's there you're selling zero
homes
and the biggest disconnect i see in real
estate is people get
way too comfortable in what's worked
and it lulls them to sleep and they
don't have the
interest in being in the
branding game they're so transactional
which is required which i love
you know what what has made me me is i
love selling
and i love branding i like branding more
because branding does selling for you
when you're not selling
nobody here dunkin donuts didn't call me
and say would you please come to our
store this morning
i didn't get a cold call from dunkin
donuts this morning saying would you
like some coffee sir
right one of my favorite clips of yours
gary is the one that you did with tommy
hilfiger and how that
brand reestablished itself because of
his brand prowess you know
um over what two decades now so
um yes i love all that we have about 10
questions that i have lined up for you
guys to go so let's
go let's go rapid fire because we don't
have a lot of time and i already went on
a rant so let's do it no you're good man
the first one before we do um i'm sorry
for
my buck summit back here i obviously
understand you're a big
fan no it's funny even though you have
the human i probably hate the most on
earth
associated with your team right now
because the bucks are an nfc team
it really doesn't i don't even hate tom
brady anywhere close to saying i was
i was kind of on like i watched the
super bowl
i wouldn't say i was cheering for tom
but like the tom brady thing
is the same thing that happened with me
with jordan on the wizards it just
doesn't matter anymore
yeah yeah so i'm fine with you and the
bucks have been bad for the majority of
my life so i
love you i'm a little bit jealous you've
won two super bowls around all that [ __ ]
but you know um no apology needed all
right we're wasting time they're gonna
be mad at us tyler yeah
fire away the first question where
should agents be trying to innovate
in 2021 clubhouse clubhouse love it i'm
gonna go i'm gonna go fast and then i'll
recall i'll either follow up or i'll
come back but tom i see you want to say
something i want to give it to you go
ahead okay
i would i would argue for youtube
pre-roll ads
gary remember three years ago sitting in
miami of course right
those right now are killing at such a
high roi
it's bonkers youtube pre-roll ads to
your point
is an obsession it's funny how we
interpreted that question tyler right
to tom's point because he has a better
pulse to it what i always have to be
careful of
is i'm so at the forefront i'm think
would you say innovate
not what's a best practice which is
right best practice is still pre-roll
youtube
and by the way stick with me here now
facebook
[ __ ] facebook is dominating right now
i don't understand people like want so
badly to go to the next thing
it's facebook creative it's the videos
yep and facebook groups if i'm
everybody on this i you know for years
i've said this in the real estate
industry
very early on in a tom ferry talking
very early on in inman talk it was kind
of my coming out party
was this whole thing that people still
to this day are doing this mayor of your
town
yep there there's an execution that will
crush for people in here
facebook groups and here's how you do it
let's use tampa
the tampa um
you go very the tampa small business
association group
and you're just hosting the party right
how would you like as a real estate
agent to throw a party in your backyard
every day of the week where everybody
comes
but it doesn't cost you any money for
refreshments and it doesn't [ __ ] up your
backyard
and your house and take up all your time
that's what starting a facebook group
that's broad
yep tampa's mother association mom's at
home
working moms from home like whatever you
do that you're passionate about you
start that facebook group and you're
the person that throws the party monster
monster so gary one of the things that's
super hot right now tactical for
everybody is if you're not comfortable
starting the group
join all of the local investment groups
in your town but not the ones that are
just on sfrs
join the multi-family duplex triplex
fourplex
so you might be the only resi agent in
that space
and everybody that owns multi-unit
everybody that owns commercial also owns
a house
and everybody just show up and
contribute don't be that sales guy gal
just
contribute be a part of it be there to
you know to learn and grow together
took the words out of my mouth if you
can if you can take your sales dna which
all of you have
out of yourself when you enter someone's
home a different facebook group
for ju it's just a little romance ladies
and gentlemen
romance go you know if you date well for
three or four times in a row
good things can happen you know a little
romance goes a long way
yeah we need to roma we need to be
humans not sales people
in those facebook groups yeah i i you
know some michael kern said
it's about time that a real estate
conference focused on tactics not just
saying feel good
so let's go very tactical start a group
and join five
in your local area on facebook commit an
hour a day
for a month and then hit up tom and i on
social media and tell us what happened
it's going to be good yeah keep going
yep no
i love that man this is a tactical
conference so anything like that is
amazing
um everybody on facebook and youtube
your comments are helping me guide
my answers so keep them coming in here
with observations or questions go ahead
ty
yes absolutely what would you tell a
well-established agent or broker that is
still
deciding between advertising through
traditional mediums like zillow
versus social media google and youtube
that life is a game of both yep
i think people are so passionate tyler
about either or
or and then somebody will say well gary
i don't have time
and then i would say yes you do audit
everything else you're doing
because you're wasting a ton of time on
dumb [ __ ] and then also i want to know
what you're doing when you're not
working
because if you're watching three hours
of netflix i need one hour back
i need one back for a little bit of both
um and then some people say well i don't
have enough money i'm like good
scale down either the social part or the
zillow part scale
one down so you come with dollars
because the game is absolutely both
yep awesome um let's see
let's get one let's get a let's get a
real tactical one tom
i want your answer on this one too if
you don't mind start
what's the number one most tactical
suggestion that you have for agents to
attract more
sellers in this market right now uh so
the thing that is outperforming
everything is a text message that you
send eight to ten a day so that here's
i'll give you just the numbers ready 181
text messages gary in a four week period
to people that are already inside your
database
so there's some know like trust some
love at some level
181 over a four week period 144
responses
42 people raised their hand and said i'm
interested 38
had a cma created so here's the value of
your home gary right like
you asked for it i'm giving it to you
don't go to zillow don't go to anybody
else's site
here's the hyperlocal experience from
that group
on average 12 research phase sellers
people that are like
hey we're a year out from moving you
know my
my mother-in-law is about to x so we're
going to move to y we're leaving new
york we're going to florida whatever it
is a year out so research phase sellers
and on average
three listings taken and then four
refunds for buyers
and then usually one or two investors
from that 181
test with about a thousand different
agents so that
that my friends is the single most
tactical thing you could do
but all it means is hey gary checking in
hope you and the family are doing great
you know the real estate market in new
york city is bonkers again
i'm curious would you like to know the
new value of your home and instead of
saying bonkers say bananas
and do like eight banana emojis because
it's gonna catch people's eyes and
imagination
and they're gonna respond to it and
that's all the text is right so if you
haven't talked to the person in five
years
you might wanna say shoot him a little
video and say hey gary checking in hope
you guys are doing great just you know
send me some love i was walking down the
street no you guys are in the
neighborhood
just wanted to say yo and then two weeks
later you send that text
but for the third of your database
that's already warmed up to you
start sending eight to ten of those text
messages a day
don't send 500 at once because you won't
be able to handle the response and
actually you're
kind of thinking about your client
experience will suffer so
and what and what eight does versus 500
is allows you to go deeper with each
individual one
which allows you to create context and
humanity
and humans are animals we smell [ __ ]
we know when we're getting a bulk and
everyone got this and it's [ __ ] you
tom instead of tyler getting a text from
me about
a free leonard fournette signing
that day now it's like wait a minute
gary actually had to write this he's not
sending a bulk to everybody about
leonard [ __ ] fournette
you know and so that yeah
yeah i've been on both sides of that
like i've done it myself i've sent a
manual text that i've done but it's been
too canned
where you know people actually think
it's an automated response
it's actually me so that that's great
perspective there to go
by the way tyler i've had that as well
through the years one of the great moves
for everybody when someone's like wait a
minute this is spam did it
you literally make a video i'd be like
i'd be like tyler
yeah i he'd spam you yep a good brother
and you said that then
then it goes then it goes triple good i
love you i actually prefer when people
reply that this isn't really you
gary on the uh like on my hey text me up
my that you hooked me up with years ago
and people go is this really tom and i'm
like hey gary it's me
like how can i help i only gave out my
number because i want to help people so
like how can i help
people freak what tom intuitively
figured out you know when he came across
a young me
and actually executed on i always give
him credit anytime i can
because it's true so many people came
across me
many people were smart enough like tom
to understand like oh [ __ ] i think he
might be up to something
almost nobody actually executed because
it's hard but what tom tom had
and the others that that it had was the
ambition
and the actions to actually match their
ambition the amount of people i meet
that are going to be millionaires
selling homes
and then like post three times on social
and like
like don't cold call because they're
scared and like like
people don't back that and so what but
what the insight is why i'm bringing
this up tyler is
he understood that scaling the
unscalable was the actual game
right right which is really not and the
reason probably worked for him was
the real estate industry prior to
modern technology was very much a dirty
you know he grew up in the game knocking
on doors like your work ethic directly
affected your outcome how many phone
calls you were willing to make
and how many doors you were willing to
knock on and how many chamber of
commerces you were willing to join
and how many local boys club this and
you know dona and donating to the you
know the little league and like
all the dirt and non-scalable stuff that
you were willing to do
was a direct attribute and when
technology came along people like oh
good i can just email blast everyone
and go to sleep right and and the right
way to use technology
is to use it in parallel to amplify your
hand-to-hand combat
you're getting your hands dirty yeah
awesome so i have four more questions we
have about
five minutes or so so let's run through
these
gary what could cause the extension or
i'm sorry what could cause the
extinction
of the real estate agent as we know it
today
i think the human being doesn't get
eliminated with technology i think
i think i do think amazon and zillow and
like big companies i i think
companies like i i think people need to
be very careful
and understand that technology will
continue to try to take you out
it's your best friend and your worst
enemy um
but humans when they make that big of a
purchase
really feel more comfortable doing it
with humans so here's what i would say i
do believe
that the big platforms will eliminate
over the next decade which is a long
period of time
the bottom 25 40 percent of agents
i think that they're just like buying a
car instead of going to a dealership
i i'll speak for myself i'm income i'm
i'm
uncomfortably comfortable buying a 10
million dollar home
through three clicks on a computer i
mean it i'm i'm not saying that to act
cool
or be weird or to prove a point
i am uncomfortably comfortable
with buying a 10 million home through
the computer and if zillow wants to set
up 5 000 people
virtually in call centers and they're in
the philippines so they can just
answer my question on like what's my
mortgage again and what's that again
and they can answer it or an ai bot
machine learning could just answer what
was the school district what are my
taxes
i will do that and so will a lot of
other people
many more people will not my father
would never do that
and and many many other people including
people younger than me will not
but what i do think will happen is that
the 25 to 30 percent weakest agents in
the game that are getting by
will have something to worry about over
the next 10 to 15 years
so gary yes sir if you're on my uh my
my rant with everybody the argument
today it's actually what you're
discussing
is coming it's already coming true the
difference is today
it's the smart marketing companies the
zillows the realtors the
quicken loans the mellow homes is they
figured out the arbitrage game because
agents won't brand themselves
and what market themselves and like my
entire argument for everybody listening
today was
you need to dig a moat around your
castle and protect your brand
beyond just putting it on steroids you
need to recognize they're all coming
directly for your commission dollars and
they're going to earn it every day
and when michael when michael says
relationships are hard to disrupt he's
right
but they're going to out flank you for
making the relationship digitally before
you make it
in real life right and the scale is the
issue
yep yep and by the way like i can see in
the comments none of these companies are
bad i'm
friends with all of these companies they
are just
following their business plan the
question is what is your plan
to make yourself a little less
disruptive three to five years
and tom when i wrote the thank you
economy and did some this is what gets
me so mad
hey that was your best book wait till
you see what i've got coming in december
i'm i'm ready
i'm ready i i agree and i think this
one's got it
anyway but nonetheless um uh
this is a big statement and and michael
inspired me which is why i like comments
i to this day can't understand how
people don't understand and i would say
90 and this is a rough guess you guys
probably will have a better number
to guess on people are atrocious
at keeping in touch with people they
already sold a home to
with no showing your card
that you actually want them to say hey
my sister's in the market
just like again i'm just gonna keep
using tyler i know exactly who i would
have been
as a as an agent i would have sold
tyler's home
and out of nowhere for no [ __ ] reason
when tampa won a good monday night game
18 months later
i would have text and be like huge win
that's it
knowing that i continue to stay top of
mind knowing that tomorrow
bruno walks into the office and goes hey
i need to i'm thinking about moving
he's like oh [ __ ] you need to talk to my
guy gary like
i can't that you know the where all the
money is
for almost everybody who's watching this
right now is the collateral relationship
graph of the people they've already sold
and did
a good transaction with yet most people
are such
hunters they keep going for a new thing
and they're not farming an old thing and
when they farm the old thing they [ __ ]
it up because it's
too like hey sally how you been by the
way any of your friends in the market
like no no no
transactional no no relationship yeah
yeah gary you literally just you just uh
reiterated
three of my big points so that was
perfect
he just answered one of my two final
questions was what would you do if you
were
a real estate agent today which
obviously that's what you would do
i apologize man i did have a hard stop i
know we yapped a little bit too much but
i hope we gave some value and i hope
everyone's well
you're good man i appreciate it i'm gary
thank you man thank you bye
bye see you guys youtube watcher what's
up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times uh i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you